[Applause]
[Music]
South Korea is one of the most liberal
and democratic countries in Asia as well
as being not surprisingly one of the
most connected and technologically
advanced countries in the world the
contrast with its impoverished and
tyrannical northern neighbor is striking
like the difference between well night
and day and in fact here on visual
politic we've already talked about some
of these differences in various videos
but this time I'm not gonna talk about
the South Korean economy orb anything
like that in this video we're gonna talk
about the internet you've probably heard
that South Korea is the number one
country in the world in terms of volume
of online connections well check this
out South Korea has the most users
connected to fiber-optic networks almost
31 percent of its entire population in
addition 96 percent of South Koreans
have access to the Internet the largest
percentage on the planet by the way
they're also the third biggest social
network users no less than 85 percent of
all South Koreans use them regularly to
give you a better idea this compares
with about 70 percent in the United
States
and that is not all nowadays it's also
the country that markets the fastest
internet speed that's two point five
gigs down that will soon become ten gigs
if that weren't enough it's the country
with the highest smartphone penetration
in the world 94% of South Koreans have
one basically South Korea is super super
connected but as if that wasn't enough
Korea wit or not the south of course has
the most implemented 4G network in the
world and has been one of the first
countries to now have the famous 5g
connection but all right you know enough
facts you get the picture South Korea
boasts amazing technological development
and an envy of all telecommunication
market but as we like to say on visual
politic take a closer look because not
everything that glitters is necessarily
gold
[Music]
according to the NGO freedom house which
creates an annual benchmark index on
network freedom South Korea barely
reaches the harshali free status this
basically puts it at the same level as
countries like Nigeria or Kyrgyzstan
which as everyone knows our amazing
democracies but that raises the question
what exactly is happening in South Korea
why do they have such a low level of
Network freedom well in this video we're
going to discuss a not so well-known
South Korean problem and that's
government control of the Internet
a censorship tradition
all countries they have their angels and
they have their demons and of course
South Korea is no different
South Korean democracy is very recent
dabeli in 1988 and is still an imperfect
democracy throughout its short life fans
without exception each and every one of
its Democratic presidents has had a
clear tendency towards censorship and
information control whether due to a
lack of political culture or because of
moral and cultural issues a link to
their Confucian past a state is still
very very paternalistic and there's a
strong hierarchical vision of society
this means that elders and bosses they
are never questioned in addition there's
a strong sense of community in
comparison to the more individualistic
and less rigid societies of the West
this really explains why the country's
leaders felt justified in controlling
certain aspects often too many of
people's lives they've also limited
their citizens ability to express
themselves freely all this is of course
in the name of the common good this
often involves controlling freedom of
speech and of course limiting criticisms
of authority figures or the ruling party
of the moment however the government
uses two issues in particular to justify
all of its censorship activity
protection against North Korea and
public morals
[Music]
you see in order to block content the
government resorts to the national
security law a law that among other
things prohibits communism in practice
as well as any declaration in favor of
North Korea or subversive ideas that
encourage the elimination of the state
this law not only applies in the
physical world but also in cyberspace
for example blocking or closing any
webpages that speak in favor of the
North's regime and then there's another
key factor that is becoming more and
more important lately and that's a ban
on pornography yep yeah that right South
Korea is one of a few countries in the
world where pornography is explicitly
prohibited specifically it's been
prohibited since 2008 specifically it's
not actually just pornography but it's
also gambling as many online games have
been blocked under the pretext of being
indecent websites but don't think that
this is new not at all see a few years
ago between 2001 and 2003 the then
governments of the center-left Nobel
Prize winner Kim died Jung said about
blocking websites with homosexual
content as if there was no tomorrow
because they were literally spaces of
obscenity and perversion quite a mild
statement there now of course if you
want to be an a sensor that is you want
to chop and change the internet to suit
your views you need to organize yourself
[Applause]
it is precisely due to this that in 2008
the conservative president Lee myung-bak
created a public body to control the
Internet the Korea Communications
Standards Commission or KC SC tonenpaul
inclusion yunjeong
ee ho song Amida
this commission has the power to block
and even close websites without even
requiring a court order the problem is
that instead of moving towards an
increasingly free Internet South Korea
seems to be heading backwards at full
speed the most recent figures from 2017
on websites blocked and eliminated by
the case ESC are pretty scary nearly 67
thousand websites were blocked ins more
than 18,000 were eliminated in a single
year and with this kind of information
you could really say the things are
getting out of hands it's scary to see
politicians blocking and closing
websites of will
[Music]
and on top of that 2017 was the first
year since the Commission began to
operate in 2008 in which the number of
blocked and deleted web pages decreased
just a little in other words it was
actually a good year hmm but having
reached this point the question that
comes to mind is how is South Korea
censoring the internet how far can the
government go to prevent the population
from accessing the immoral and what's
even more important could visual politic
be considered to be an immoral website
well let's see
Tangled independent sensor
the truth is that censorship in the
South Korean Network is very serious and
it is not transparent and the key to all
of this is the kc SC which i mentioned
just a moment ago this so-called
independent commission is nestled within
another Korea's Communications
Commission or KCC the ke CSU regulates
the internet and the KCC regulates all
means of communication and the key
question is how do they work well the
KCC has five members two of which aren't
directly appointed by the South Korean
president including its director the
other three are appointed by the
National Assembly the country's
parliament so as you can absolutely see
it's a non-political and unbiased
Commission which is all rather
independence in this way the KC SC the
Commission that regulates the Internet
is responsible for identifying websites
that violate any law sites such as
pro-north websites pornography or online
gambling but also anything that the
agency considers as cyber defamation or
anti military content that's when a
Content deletion blocking or total
closure of the website request is issued
to the KCC which transmits it to the
media service provider who must comply
with the order and these kinds of
requests they aren't often rejected
however officially the service provider
has 15 days to appeal the request the
truth is that after the deadline it is
the KC SC you decides what sanctions and
punishments will be applied based on the
law and the content in question and do
keep in mind here that no judge at any
point interferes with this process so
what do you think of this to us it just
sounds like outright censorship which
clashes with the foundations of freedom
and democracy
that's not all in 2017 a new president
came to power human rights lawyer moon
jae-in seized power after a shady
corruption scandal involving his
conservative predecessor Park geun-hye
many in the Western media painted him as
a reformer who would bring new progress
to the country but is it really like
this in the field of Internet freedom
well no I can conclusively tell you that
this is not the case so listen up
[Music]
hoonjae a heavy hand and a pretty face
you saw here on this channel first in a
previous video we criticized moon jae-in
for his economic management's but what
about individual liberties and more
specifically the internet because we're
basically talking about a center-left
politician who has been trying to convey
the image that South Korea has overcome
a dark era of corruption after the
scandals of his predecessor Park he did
this with a campaign that washed his
image with quite populist dyes it's a
campaign with which he obtained a
chilling approval rating of 80 percent
among the South Koreans at the beginning
of his mandate quite the popular forever
there
in addition is dialogues with North
Korea and summits with Kim jong-un who
have also helped him be seen as a man of
peace and reconciliation both inside and
outside of Korea but also on justice
because really is it all as rosy as it
seems well know if his economic
management is already leaving quite a
lot to be desired in terms of individual
liberties and Network freedom he is not
doing too well either censorship is a
bipartisan pursuit in South Korea yes
according to a report by the Jun yang
Lee Bo one of the three largest
newspapers in South Korea censorship in
the moon' era has expanded even more in
the political arena for example the moon
government withdrew funding from the
only think-tank in the United States
that specializes in Korean issues the
u.s. Career Institute or the u.s. ki why
well it didn't have to do with austerity
but with the u.s. ki being critical of
moons overly friendly attitudes with Kim
jong-un and his North Korean regime
green think-tank at u.s. university to
close after Seoul withdraws funding
[Music]
mind you the problem isn't that he
withdrew financing from a think tank in
Washington but the idea of using public
money to reward friends and punish
critics but that's not all the most
serious and most worrisome points that
the international community is the new
form of censorship that moons government
is implemented on the Internet it is
considered Chinese style censorship
because it's the same method that
Beijing uses to block websites yeah you
heard that right
South Korea is copying China in terms of
freedoms you probably didn't expect that
one since the start of this year 2019
the South Korean government has begun to
open date packages from encrypted HTTPS
websites servers which are considered to
be the safest the que CSC used server
name identification or SN is Pia nosh to
block 895 websites in February using
this method
one of the websites blocked with this
method was for example the largest
pornographic website in the world but
how does this method work well we'll
check this out if the user tries to
access an HTTPS website considered
harmful by the government the KC SC
opens the date packages defined the
server whose information is not
encrypted that way by knowing the server
the government can block access to these
harmful sites
[Music]
that's not old if the government comes
up with the key to decrypt the
information it can even specifically see
your internet visits and access personal
information such as your IP address in
short moons government could be spying
on every packet of data that South
Korean citizens receive and then they
could choose to block access if it's an
unauthorized page that is they can
control what each person does on the
internet as an individual level makes us
answer the question of whether South
Koreans have any privacy with a
resounding no and it goes without saying
that this is not typical of democratic
regimes or leaders with a conciliatory
image such as moons but here a visual
politic we really do love South Korea
and we really believe that it's an
exemplary country in most aspects it's
precisely because we love it that we're
worried about this lack of networked
freedom but I was your turn is the
censorship and espionage of Internet
users justified in order to maintain
morals what do you think about the
online control framework that South
Korea has developed it's been really
committed to freedom well leave your
answers in the comments and in this
survey and I really do hope you enjoyed
this video please hit like if you did
and don't forget to subscribe you got
brand new video several times a week
don't forget to check out our friends as
well at the reconsider media also just
before I go today do you want to give a
quick plug to another political YouTube
channel the channel is called hypocrite
twins and it tackles political topics
from both sides of the political
spectrum in a really clever way it's
also very funny so if you're into
politics which you are and if you're
into comedy which I think you will enjoy
it's a channel you'll definitely want to
check out like who runs the channel has
a short clip about internet censorship
in South Korea and this really reflects
the rest of his content so if you like
this clip which I think you will please
do go over and subscribe to his channel
you will find a link to do that's in the
description this is not a paid spot or
anything it's just something that I
thought you guys might enjoy and over to
Alec I've traveled to the planet earth
to understand your society but I'm
confused by South Korea South Korea is
one of the few developed nations with
internet censorship well they're one of
the only countries to admit that they
have it in America Google and Facebook
only have technical difficulties if
you're conservative
you should use this to your advantage so
next time you're about to be caught
cheating on your girlfriend let me see
your phone right now shout into google
voice I love Donald Trump's immigration
policy here yo babe every one of your
accounts is deleted for hate speech
South Korea's internet censorship on
porn distribution of porn is a two-year
felony even the word homosexuality is
banned from libraries what I want to
know is do they put all the porn
offenders in the same prison if so that
might motivate them to break the law
faster I'm here for porn I'm here for
porn - homosexual porn what's that word
mean I never taught it to me at the
library
why is internet censorship bizarre for
South Korea when it exists in other
places on your planet well in South
Korea it's so bizarre because they're a
global leader in communication
technology dude is it true that Samsung
invented a telepathy machine nobody
knows if it works or not
because we can't go six seconds without
thinking about sex and then our thoughts
are blocked another huge part of South
Korea's censorship is to stop the
influence of the north however if I were
Kim jong-eun I'd abuse the South
censorship to transmit covert military
intelligence to my own troops because
nothing could be intercepted so long as
every message sounded like a porn script
captain I've intercepted a transmission
that says the hard rocket is about to
blow prematurely on the rear you can't
look at that shut it down but it's
urgent I know how to enforce our
censorship hold that up
I will have Donald Trump's immigration
policy all right now functioned that was
a clip from hypocrite twins like I said
I'm gonna link to that in the
description below as always I'll see you
next time
[Music]